two things I want to ask before we
before we uh some you know one of them
has to do with the uh where you're at
one is uh are you following the Disney
story what's going on with Disney
very Loosely I personally don't watch or
pay attention to the news at all I'll
read some articles but I I think I have
an understanding of it by the way
Disney's been canceled so many times by
so many groups over the years it's just
like some people are mad at Disney now
okay
it's what you're saying is it's constant
that happens constantly they're
constantly being canceled it's just not
the first time in my lifetime of being
aware of Disney that there's been a
group pissed off at Disney this is
slightly different though this is
slightly different because you know uh
you know Charlie Cora did you see the
story with Charlie Cora uh Disney airs
and high school teacher comes out as
trans slams Florida education law you
know the great grandchild of the late
Roy Disney who co-founded Disney with
the younger brother Walt has come out as
transgender is going to on the attack
against Florida's parental rights and
education law Cora said that lgbtq
people already face rates of depression
anxiety bullying and suicide they put
then put aside uh something like that as
a law they can't learn about our
community and their history or play
sports or use bathroom they want to use
the claim is not entirely true the
education Bill only prevents Florida
children so you know you said something
interesting you said back in the days it
was them trying to silence uh uh you
know
and then today now is this the extremes
being on both sides but uh uh I think
the pendulum swings man I think I think
it's swung radically left and
unfortunately it's gonna swing radically
right yeah probably and so for me I
don't find that I really can get down
with either of those extreme sides I'm
I'm a guy who's just like I'm interested
in people I find people fascinating I'm
interested into the solutions people
have and I'm interested in all of it I I
don't want to like discount anybody but
but
this this whole thing over this law in
Florida I I read the law the law is not
saying what they're saying the law is
saying for me
I don't want I I mean it doesn't seem
like an opportune time to teach kids
about sexuality from kindergarten to
third grade that's my perception on kids
so the idea of not teaching them that
not informing them on things like that
especially I think that should be the
job of the parents I I so I don't
understand why they're so freaked out
about it by the way there's nowhere in
the bill that it says don't say gay
nowhere in the bill yeah that's just
called great marketing but but one of
the things that uh one of did you want
to say something I was going to say you
you brought up yesterday the pendulum
swings yeah we're bringing about today I
think that is America I mean not not
even just politically societally
everything just comes down to I mean
think about it since 1980 we've had
Reagan
pendulum's never gone right with Disney
no I'm not even saying
Disneyland
then you go to Bill Clinton and then you
go to back to Bush and then you go to
Obama and then you go to Trump like
that's America and then we're just
constantly grappling yeah what the
center of gravity is the cartoonists in
Disney used to put dicks in the cartoons
The Little Mermaid and the other you
talk about the Box yeah and the box of
little mermaids cover that's what you're
talking about but but what it was in the
actual Stills they would hide in the
cartoons themselves they would hide
phalluses and graphic stuff in all this
um and and they've removed a lot of it's
not just that you can like look for
instances of um graphic images in Disney
cartoons I what the hell is that all
about well I'm just saying there were
times where religious groups were
furious with Disney about this well I
I'm just a normal person not religious
why are you hiding dicks it's just not
the first time
people have been bent out of shape about
what Disney and then there were there
was a time where you know I don't think
this is true yeah right there I mean
that is a clearly a [ __ ] and ball
[Laughter]
um but and the Little Mermaid I remember
on the cover of The Little Mermaid I
remember someone behind the scenes is
basically saying I'm trying to Rude kids
lives are obviously it impacted Adam's
life I remember thinking Ariel was
pretty hot and then there was a dick
very angry with Disney the left was
angry with Disney because he wasn't
unionizing his workers so there was a
time period where Disney was persistent
but that's Anger from the left no I
don't know I don't know about that I
think that's different because and of
course I know the story I've been to the
San Francisco Disney Museum that they
have I don't know if you've been there
it's pretty sad it's sick I mean it's if
you ever go to San Fran you have to go
to the Disney Museum it's got a lot of
good stuff there but that's different
didn't they call Walt Disney a Nazi or a
Nazi sympathizer that's
from the left I know oh I know what I'm
saying is there's a difference between
the end they're always going to Target
the guy at the top of any company that's
that comes with the territory bro if
you're going to make a lot of money
you're going to have power you're gonna
have influence shit's gonna be talked
about you
this is trying to influence kids this is
different this is the CEO saying 50 of
the characters are gonna be dot dot dot
that that that's influencing the kids in
a in a way that scares the crap out of
parents on both sides I don't think it's
political anymore because I think
regardless of your Democrat libertarian
independent Republican you're a parent
first if you got kids and you got four
kids I got four kids so we we look at it
from a different perspective and the
Florida bill says third grade I'm like
dude what third grade you shouldn't do
it till High School what we I don't care
if it's fourth grade you mean to tell me
fourth grade is okay when is sex ed talk
teach it then health and guidance is
that that's six that was seventh grade
there's two levels yeah there's yeah so
the the banana and the the the condom
and then you got the help and guidance I
don't know why it's being discussed
before that to be honest I'm we're on
the same page I don't disagree with you
if you enjoyed this short clip click
over here to watch another short clip
and if you want to watch the entire
episode the entire podcast click here
[Music]